today we check in with the fat community  over at tiktok a realm that we may call  thick talk i'm gonna prove to you why  white people are the reason i'm fat  today  if white people didn't go looking for  spices then a various sea routes to  indian subcontinent and africa and other  places of the world would not get  discovered  and if they didn't get discovered then  east india company would never come to  indian subcontinent  and if they didn't come  then the fertility of the land would not  get destroyed because they forced us to  cultivate tobacco and dies in opioid  things like that and that destroyed the  fertility of my country it's a fun game  i have to admit it's like it's like the  self-victimizing version of seven  degrees of kevin bacon i can do this too  you know for instance i tend to be  impatient and at times ill-tempered i  admit it's not my fault though it can  actually be traced directly back to  alexander the great's invasion of persia  in 334 bc